if the world were to end tomorrow the
happiest segment of the week if the
world were to end tomorrow what would
happen with all the hall of famers and
we say that look it's amazing how many
people take it literally when i pose
that question
obviously there would be no hall of fame
there would be no hall of fame ceremony
if the world would end tomorrow we'd all
be dead these these issues would
instantly become moot so to placate
those who
want to you know point out that it's
impossible
to have a hall of fame ceremony if the
world ran tomorrow if football would go
away tomorrow
who gets in that's currently playing we
talked about several of the positions
last week shireen
this week let's start with the running
backs right adrian peterson
is the one who somehow is still playing
is now positioned to be the starter and
the bell cow
for the washington football team because
of the release of darius geiss
beyond adrian peterson the first ballot
lock
who else do you see playing running back
right now who has a chance
of getting in if the sport were to end
tomorrow
well you know last last week we did 10
years or less and
and i'm going to talk about a guy who's
played way longer than 10 years and
that's frank gore and
you know i think he's done a lot of
great things i think you know he's going
to end up in
obviously the top three in rushing all
time so i think you've got to consider
uh frank gore for the hall of fame and
and i don't know that he's going to be
first
ballot you know he didn't he made all
decade finally and
you know he's made uh know all pro teams
but but
just his sheer numbers and the length of
his career i think you've got to put
frank gore in the hall of fame
eventually
uh but that's where i would start
probably with adrian peterson who to me
is a lock
and frank gore would be the two guys i i
think have the best chance obviously of
going into the hall of fame
when frank gore's name comes up and
people say oh all he's done is played a
long time i see do you not realize how
hard it is to play a long time at that
position
to continue to continue to line up
every year i feel like between gore and
peterson they will continue to play
as long as someone gives them a job and
gives them a helmet and puts them on the
field
they both can pass emmett smith the
question is will there be enough teams
that let them have the opportunity to
compile the yards necessary
to pass emmett smith so i i just think
that
you know it's one thing for a kicker to
play as long as frank gore has it's
another
sorry kickers but it's the truth it's
another thing for frank gore to be out
there
getting banged around on every single
time that he touches the football
it's amazing what he's done and and i
think he should be a first ballot hall
of famer
i especially because who else is in that
bucket
we've got quarterbacks we've got
receivers we've got passwords we've got
everything
but there aren't many running backs that
stand out beyond peterson and gore
marshawn lynch i don't know he's another
guy who's been around more than 10 years
but still for running backs we we can't
apply that limitation is he a guy who's
done enough to get it to get in
if he never plays again i think it's
really close you know
we talked a little bit last week about
the all decade team it used to be if you
made the first team all decade team you
were in the hall of fame
aside from drew pearson but you were in
automatically the
football hall of fame it it happened at
some point
but now they changed the process this
year so instead of having a first team
in a second team it's all
lumped together and so the the all
decade running backs were marshawn lynch
lashawn mccoy adrian peterson and frank
gore
in this last one and so i think you have
to consider him because he made all
decade but i don't think
all decade is as relevant as it once was
with all of them being lumped in
together to me there weren't four
all-decade
running backs you needed to have two on
the first team and two on the sega team
but that's the way it was done but i do
think he has a shot
i'd like to see him play again uh you
know another year or two because i think
he has that in him
maybe somebody gives him a chance late
in the season like seattle did last
season but i think he's really close to
being a hall of fame running back
i think he's now firmly in that roger
clemens mode that that i personally
thought brett favre would do for a year
or two
at the end of his career or tacked on to
it where
you just show up for late december and
january and you try to get one more
super bowl win
and that would cement it i think if he
could just pull that off i think it
would make it a no-brainer for now it's
a close call
other guys look i mean ezekiel elliott's
on track right
but but he would have questions he
hasn't done enough he hasn't done enough
to get in if he's if
if football goes away tomorrow right no
no question 115
yards a little over 5 000 yards he's
been great
in the four years he's played but yeah
he needs to do way more than what he's
done
so far you know one guy i didn't realize
had as many yards as he did was mark
ingram he's 64th with over 7 000 yards
but i wouldn't put mark ingram in that
category either i think he's got to do
much more in his career
to get into the hall of fame and so if
it ended yeah if it ended today i'm not
putting mark
ingram or ezekiel elliott in the hall of
fame and lashawn mccoy is
kind of one who i think is right there
on the edge as well what do you think of
lesean mccoy
yeah look i i i right now probably would
say no but what would help him is the
fact that there just
aren't many running backs and there
won't be many running backs because of
the way the game has changed
so you know when we get 10 15
20 25 years out if the world doesn't end
and if i'm still around to watch it
at some point lesean mccoy's name is
gonna sneak through the cracks because
the argument's gonna be
we haven't put a running back in in a
while now between christian mccaffrey
and ezekiel elliott that that's going to
change but even beyond i mean
really how many running backs right now
are even on track
to have a chance at the hall of fame
you've got mccaffrey you've got
elliott you know it's too premature for
a guy like a dalvin cook he's had one
healthy year it's way too premature for
me to be unbelievable
just on a lot of guys he's gonna have to
have a career rebirth
starting now now not next year not with
his next team
he's got to rediscover his pittsburgh
form now
to get back in that in that position so
at some point
at some point you know based on and look
i i know that what happens in the room
is is discreet and private and secret
but i've heard enough from people not
you
i don't want to get you in trouble i've
heard from other voters enough to come
to the conclusion
that at some point somebody's going to
stand up and say we haven't had a
running back in five years it's time to
put a running back in and that's going
to help lesean mccoy get in
yeah and it very well could you're
exactly right and
and i do think that does happen uh you
know it happened with the safety
position lord we you know we didn't put
safeties in forever and now it seems
like we're putting a safety in every
year
to try to make up for that bat log and i
think you're going to see that with with
tight ends and eventually as you said
with running backs because there just
aren't a lot of running backs
uh in this class playing right now it's
become such a passing league that
and the running backs have such short
careers where we're putting them in
year after year after year and i do
think we're going to hit that law
after the adrian petersons and frank
gore's where we are going to look back
and we're going to say boy it's been
five years six years seven years
whatever it's been
since we've put a running back in adrian
peterson was the last we've got
we've got to put a running back uh in in
the hall of fame and that does happen
and i think it will happen in this case
and we maybe see a guy who goes in who
is right there on the edge like a lashon
mccoy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports